real Rejects
real Rejects
relate to start the story they were way
later weeks after the premiere after so
many patrons uh or super sexy rejects
have been requesting this I was like all
right okay yeah let's do this we're
going to churn out our reactions for one
of the most popular Netflix series
apparently
Wednesday I'm excited to see it only
because people keep harassing us at our
patreon page and that harassment has
paid off John how are you I am excited
I'm looking forward to this how are you
good good you're you're Adam Sandler guy
aren't you I have an Addams Family Guy
I'm an Adam's Family Guy
he said it ladies and gentlemen you know
what to do you got to leave a like
that's the first request that we have
for you guys helps out the video doesn't
take too much effort on your own please
go ahead and do it also uh subscribe
click that notification Bell because
yeah we got to get through all eight of
these episodes you want to get notified
when our reaction is up as always full
length rash watch along as we sync up
with your own copy are available for a
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
and over there we cover some shows
exclusively uh at the same tier with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included thank you to all of our patrons
who have helped us have a very
successful year at the reject Nation
let's see what all the hype is about I
haven't seen anything about this let's
see what's going on
foreign
I'm not sure whose Twisted idea it was
to put hundreds of adolescents in
underfunded schools
run by people whose dreams were crushed
years ago
this guy good morbid point it feels like
an 80s high school movie man just as
colorful
Pugsley
I want names don't know who they were it
happened so fast hugsley emotion equals
weakness
pull yourself together
smack him
psychic abilities I'm not about to
confess to my brother that I've recently
been plagued by visions I feel like
electroshock therapy but without
dissatisfying afterburn
what are you gonna do
what I do best murder
[Music]
she's got that walk down they had to be
swimmers didn't they
the only person who gets to torture my
brother is me
oh no
oh God
oh that is cruel
oh yeah go get him
oh yeah
[Music]
can I already feel it get the main guy
oh
yeah
what an opening contain your Glee
oh this is gonna be fun yeah
guest starring them oh Danny Elfman did
the music
hey Tim Burton directed it huh
[Music]
Lurch
oh my goodness I promise you my little
Piper you will love Nevermore I have no
interest in following in your footsteps
becoming captain of the fencing team
Queen of the dark prom president of the
Scion Society say on society you'll
learn about emotion that boy's family
was going to file attempted murder
charges how would that have looked on
your record terrible pretty great
everyone would know I failed to get the
job done
eyes of the prize Wednesday
[Laughter]
some kind of not exactly Hogwarts School
but kind of it runs right past Nevermore
the school for outcasts that's a polite
way of putting it oh so Nevermore is
kind of like Xavier School
basically
[Music]
God damn werewolves there's been murder
and someone's responsible Wednesday is
certainly a unique name there she is
did your mother tell you we were
roommates back in the day
and you graduated with your sanity
intact
impressive
ouch
I've assigned you to your mother's old
dorm Ophelia Hall ah Ophelia is the one
who killed herself after being driven
mad by her family Shakespeare fan
yep
welcome to Ophelia Hall
not a hugger
alert you to color what happens to you
I break out into hives and then the
flesh peels off my bones yikes
perfect opposite for Wednesday
welcome to the quad definitely looks a
bit like Hogwarts or the things
AKA vampires check that bunch of
Knuckleheads are first AKA werewolves
werewolves I'm assuming scales are
sirens
you catch on quick and Batgirl Bianca
Barclay is the closest thing Nevermore
has to loyalty
oh my
God cool she's today a resident tortured
artist Xavier Thorpe but they broke up
the beginning of the semester resident
tortured
she totally chowed down on that kid she
murdered you better watch your back hey
Jax this is my new roommate Wednesday is
he a Medusa here I'm black and white
like a living Instagram filter ignore
him Gorgon spent way too much time
getting stoned
stoned I know you should really get on
Insta Snapchat and tick tock
I find social media to be a soul-sucking
void of meaningless affirmation thank
you yes follow me at the Greg album yes
queen
look at you my little death trap
any plans you have of running away and
right now I will escape this educational
penitentiary
I got you a little
what's up w
and it's made of obsidian
which Aztec priest used conservations
ah and it'll help you solve some motives
I am not you mother
I will never fall in love or be a
housewife or have a family or accept
this direct metaphor for that you're
more like than you realize Wednesday my
little scorpion won't be alone
let's do this
what the hell did you do to my room
dividing our room equally that's some
great production design silence would be
appreciated
this is my riding time your writing time
with the loudest machine possible by the
way there are two D's in atoms if you're
going to gossip about me at least spell
my name correctly
turn that off
this is your final warning oh
hey you aware cat evening girls oh sorry
about the mud wanted to make sure it was
settling in
if you're serious regular I guess
it's cool Tim Burton brings her back she
played Wednesday that's cool I want to
go over a few house rules lights off at
10 no loud music and no boys ever yeah
okay
that's really cool they got her on the
show yeah that's really cool
oh my God she's got Action Hero skills
doesn't she she's gonna do several
backflips maybe if you whined Less in
practice more you wouldn't suck
seriously coach when am I gonna get some
real competition right now
you must be the psychopath they let in
and you must be the self-appointed queen
bee interesting thing about bees pull
out their stingers and they drop dead
let's go kill her decapitate her
Wednesday
become your mother
[Music]
oh man I love a good fencing scene
point to Wednesday
ouch I wonder how many times this was
actually Jenna Ortega Corey's even
made her mad now for the final point I
would like to invoke a military
challenge no masks no tips
winner draws First Blood
let's do it don't be a coward Bianca
nice get her oh dang oh wowie
oh [ __ ] no one makes me bleed my own
blood your face finally got that splash
of color it's so desperately needed
yikes
so like General Ortega is like perfect
she really is she just like has this
gravitational pull on the whole screen
sorry about that
Nick no good deed goes unpunished Danny
Elfman had fun scoring this show every
scene has so much music I know that's
got to be like an auxiliary character
foreign
the umbrella too
art guy tortured artist torture an
artist guy of course welcome back
if it makes you feel any better let's
just say I returned the favor it was my
Godmother's funeral
apparently she was friends with your
grandmother and they spent their 20s
together in Europe swindling the rich
and notorious
cool decided to play hide and seek I had
the inspired idea to hide in her casket
headed to the crematorium I had heard
muffled screams I just figured your
godmother had somehow cheated death and
was trying to claw her way out either
way you hit the big red stop button and
save me from being flame broiled so
now we're even
oh
could have both had an imaginative death
I knew it
hello thing
did you really think my highly trained
old factory sense wouldn't pick up on
the Fate whiff of Neroli and Bergamot in
your favorite hand lotion oh
mother and father sent you to spy on me
didn't they
you have two options
[ __ ] you in here for the rest of the
semester
when you go slowly insane trying to claw
your way out
two
you pled your own dying loyalty to me
do it do it things
bend the knee
I wonder who who they hire to play thing
because they're doing a great job on
emoting so much through that one hand I
want to know what that audition was like
yeah you got to do a lot you feel like
there's a face there well I'm doing like
sign language in that position too like
it's a cool addition
name for chocolate principal Williams
this feeble attempt at bonding is
Beneath You Miller and go hey yeah
I hope we can forge a relationship based
on trust you are not the right therapist
for her
my personal philosophy is killer be
killed so for instance when someone
bullies your brother your response is to
dump piranha in the pool you know the
old saying never bring a knife to a
sword fight
unless it's concealed
I have no remorse for your actions
that's why you're here he lost a
testicle
I did the world a favor people like
Dalton shouldn't be allowed to procreate
I've answered all your questions
we're not done yet oh interesting you
might be the right therapist editors are
short-sighted fear-based life forms one
wants to square my writing as
gratuitously morbid and suggested I seek
psychiatric help
hence
I sent her a thank you
[Music]
would you mind if I use the powder room
first
okay
is everything okay I think Tim Burton
did a great job with this pilot yeah
it's restrained but still stylish
you have to find the right tone where
you don't get
two inch respective of our ruins The
Morbid fun it's literally playing cat
and mouse with emotional development
yes put those creepers to work
[Music]
you got that weirdo
let him die that reminds me of that
Christopher Walken sketch from SNL
I mean spoiler alert for your special
machines having a seizure so
all we have is Drew a truck is for
people who hate themselves and know
their lives have no real purpose or
meaning
it's gonna leave that here
I'm Tyler by the way I didn't catch your
name or is that on a need to know basis
too
Wednesday
do not hate you I could Burling to
myself perfect
I don't get off for another hour
you do now I can't be bought so either
wait or find someone else to drive you
so much respect
Tyler you'd be good for her
[Music]
oh
great pilgrims
eat me what's the never more freak going
out in the wild this is our booth
why are you three just like religious
fanatics
pilgrims potato potato we work at
Pilgrim world
oh girl world
it takes a special kind of stupid to
devote an entire theme park to zealots
responsible for Mass genocide
have you ever been on the Normie
I've never found one that could handle
me she's got them comebacks dude
what's up
big wide swings
so where do you learn those Kung Fu
moves my uncle taught me we spent five
years in the Tibetan monastery
Monk prisoner
polish Sheriff this one's slipped away
from me come on Miss Adams time to go
you're in Adams oh no tell me Gomez
Adams is your father
that man belongs Behind Bars from murder
guessing the Apple doesn't fall far from
the tree I'm gonna keep my eye on you
okay
the challenge accepted she always picks
the rights moments a smile
gross Wowie
[Music]
let's go Apocalyptica
[Music]
oh I like this dude she actually learned
how to work the neck
[Music]
Tom Riddle
he's like the combination of Tom Riddle
and uh David crumb holds from Adam's
Family Values
foreign
[Music]
I guess so maybe Gomez killed his wife
awesome
[Music]
right
[Music]
foreign
no I don't really feel better
where's the rest of him it's one of the
great Adams Family Mysteries
now we need a whole origin series
spin-off why aren't you wolfing out
because I can't I've been to the best
like an ologist had to play to Milwaukee
would you believe it
yeah she says there's a chance I might
never
my life would be officially over my
feather always framed like it yeah
why are you crying because I'm upset
haven't you ever cried are you above
that too I cried once on top of a
mountain tears of joy after murdering
someone
I was six years old I took my pet
scorpion Nero out for his afternoon
stroll when we were ambushed I have a
nice cream
they wondered what kind of freak would
have a scorpion for a pet oh
two of them held me down and made me
watch
oh no
buddy
front Nero
oh that is cruel must be a core memory
cried my little black heart out
[Music]
that is a really cool Tombstone with the
Black Dahlia to top it off
your secret's safe with me I still think
you're weird as [ __ ] though the feeling
is incredibly Mutual they have really
good chemistry yeah
they don't sound like they're reading
lines together no sound like just an
actual scene a couple of other actors I
wouldn't say the same yeah
okay
oh [ __ ]
I harm one hair on things Palm reverse
Palm this isn't weird at all
cool
you should have led with that yeah
just High
roll over that's thing
you see
like your pit
there's the Harvest Festival this
weekend attendance is mandatory if
you're still willing to drive me to the
train station I can make it worth your
while considered a freebie
why at least one of us will get out of
this hellhole town
stand up to your dad doesn't exactly
feel 100 like old Tim Bergen but like
big fish Timber you know a little bit
around that time was Tim Burton's career
big eyes big fish
still better than like 99 of things Tim
Burton does today yeah I'll take this
yeah
or whatever else
I haven't seen Riverdale but this
gives me Vibes of what I've heard about
Riverdale yeah but Sabrina probably has
some yeah thematic tissue with this get
any better at this you'll be taking home
a whole pack pandas don't travel in
packs they prefer the Solitude subtle
hint taken I'm gonna stick around
you see that sad lonely woman over there
would you mind distracting her
girl you got money despair I know
it's your side hustle Wednesday
it's your dad's police file for me was
it Nevermore
not used to people engaging with me
coming across the street
scary you just kinda
spooky
and mysterious and spooky
and altogether ookie
that's a Jesus Christ Resurrection act
we can lose them in the crowd
I think Wednesday could take them on
oh no
[Music]
oh girl you're gonna need to stay behind
face The Raven
face the raven come back
how many guy friends has went there how
many pales from what blonde white guy
friends who all look like leads in
various Tim Burton movies what do you
want
why are you following me I don't have
time to explain but you're in danger
you're gonna end up like the lanky guy
from stranger things I think you've got
it backwards I am the danger
the gargoyle that was you
girl in the picture that's you
oh
put me down no my mother said it was my
destiny to stop this girl if she ever
came to Nevermore because she will
destroy the school and everyone in it
wow you need more evidence
[Music]
foreign
there's a mislead
golly Let Yourself Go the eyes look like
that truck driver but I'm wondering if
it's the cop's son
no torture artist The Mysteries
that I could potentially destroy the
school and was mysteriously saved by a
homicidal monster I think I'm going to
love it here
laughs
[Music]
Kudos nice
the story is about to take a dark turn
again are we supposed to wash us I don't
feel like it's necessary
yeah I'm gonna stop this just in case
yeah we're gonna watch it
I don't know if that was like something
shot just for this as a joke but uh see
if you can yell at us in the comments if
we're supposed to be watching yeah
all right let's talk about that's great
that was really well done that was a
really really well done well this is one
of those Netflix reactions so you know
what that means that the review part of
this we will attempt to keep it short
because there's uh really no point most
you guys already know what how the show
ends and you're really much let's just
move on to the next one next episode
we'll talk about it a little bit I think
a pilot deserves it I thought this was a
really solid pilot I think that would I
mean I was really drawn to the fact that
Tim Burton I didn't know he directed it
I thought I heard his name was attached
but I didn't know he was someone who
actually held any of the episodes so to
uh it gave me a different kind of
observant eye because I'm uh I haven't
watched some of his later films I I have
seen some of later films but you know
some of his earlier workers some of my
favorite films of all time sure and it
was cool to see some more of that Tim
Burton Flair uh come back and I think
what they're doing here with setting up
a because it doesn't like while there's
the winks and nods to Adam's Family it
doesn't feel
reliant on it like I think you can watch
this without having had any awareness of
Adam's Family while there's elements
that play on a certain element of
nostalgia and certain Winks it doesn't
feel like it's necessary to be aware of
Adam's Family to enjoy it because even
with its like Macabre tone I think the
way how Tim Burton struck a certain
specific kind of tone with its narrative
because they're doing something where
you are doing a bit more of an
introspective look at Wednesday Adams
and putting her into more of a modern
day world obviously because we're
talking about social media and all that
[ __ ] so it takes place in modern day
and yet it still has an old-school Flair
to it while simultaneously doing a lot
more of this type of morbid Macabre
sensibility it's not
it's it doesn't I when it's when they
introduce like the therapy segment
sometimes a thing can get like kind of
um
divided in itself the project can get
divided of like what what exactly kind
of energy or story are we trying to tell
and it doesn't try to go too realistic
on Wednesday atoms which you can't
really do but you can do just enough to
kind of understand or like you get her
traumatic backstory with her pet
scorpion and uh examining some parts of
her upbringing that she does feel
resentful towards and I like this uh
Journey that they they set up with her
and needless to say Jenna Ortega is uh
as as anything you see general or take
it she again is right spot she's perfect
she's she's absolutely perfect in this
role I I can see her becoming and maybe
she is for some people already the
definitive Wednesday atoms and I think
that's pretty neat to have Christina
Ritchie in here too uh as some as the
person who's like done works with Tim
Burton in the past some of his best work
and some of her best work and of course
being once they added it was it two
films there's two films yeah yeah both
the Barry sonenfeld films yeah yeah so
that's pretty cool to have her return
there's a lot I really liked about it
there are some little qualms that I
don't feel like overshadow my experience
that I'll go into
uh but for now this is my positives
there's more to positively highlight
like music and [ __ ] but want a thin one
hump frontin this what did you think
good sir Ramble On yeah Ramble On I like
this I like this as a pilot a new pilots
can be kind of you know tricky but I
thought this nailed itself down as a
nice kind of well proportioned piece and
yes uh as somebody who too has a lot of
love for various Tim Burton joints and a
lot of wariness for where his career is
currently at
I kind of got what you meant when you
said part way through the episode like
it it doesn't feel like the most Tim
Burton it could possibly be it doesn't
feel like this is a full-on Tim Burton
movie iteration of what an atoms family
world would look like however I feel
like this is kind of the right
environment for him because you know
with the budgets of these kinds of
series you don't have you you can get to
the point where you have huge effects
budgets but clearly right now this show
isn't relying on those and so I feel
like there's enough kind of restriction
to keep Tim Burton in the tangible where
I think he works arguably the best some
of the time and this is a series I think
we'll probably have at least a few other
directors in the mix and so there's also
that element of like yeah I feel like
even if he is a huge guiding creative
voice on this it won't just be the Tim
Burton show and and yeah while parts of
me are like oh man go even further I'm
also happy to see that yeah right now
they're taking their time to gradually
set this up and to find the tone and
balance between being just comic strip
enough but not too comic strip like you
pointed out and so coming into this I
had reasons to be wary just because
this is a Wednesday Adams and The Adams
Family are characters that lend
themselves to this kind of thing but
this is also very Here and Now
take where it is very Riverdale very
Sabrina very sort of like okay we're
gonna make her some kind of mystery
solver we're gonna put her at the core
of a lot of converging
storytelling factors that are very
popular to right now and it could go
either way and right now at least I feel
like it's going in a in a direction that
I'm happy to keep following and that
doesn't you know give me at least right
now it's not ringing the wariness bell
of like oh here we go you know like I'm
actually happy to see Wednesday grow uh
in herself as well as you know kind of
confronting her ability to interface
with other people and I've heard people
say that Wednesday is sort of coded in a
sort of autistic kind of way not to not
to you know be insensitive but to
actually just be like that's kind of how
they are portraying uh just the way she
experiences the world as a character and
I think that's kind of a neat and
interesting undertone and that kind of
helps actually to inform the stuff
that's real the stuff about being an
outcast and the stuff about being
misunderstood for just how you engage
with the world and I feel like that is
stuff that for a Wednesday Adam's like
character you can Shine the light on and
expound upon and make interesting while
also not dispelling the Mystique of the
character and it was like a great choice
where they're like how did thing become
what he is and they're like I don't know
it's one of the great Adams Family
Mysteries I was like good it seems like
they have a good grip on where to flesh
out versus where to keep the mystery and
keep the comic strip slightness that
yeah then goes to sell the sort of Rye
sardonic nature of this whole universe
in general so yeah I think they they did
The Fish Out of Water nicely but they
also gave you a big fish yay big fish
out of
Lady in the Water is a shyam lines it's
not like a Tim Burton water pun is there
I'll get there someday Planet of the
Apes all of us men folk haha
um but yeah yeah I'm excited to see
where this goes I I would I'm glad we
saw the rest of the Adams family here
and if we're gonna see anybody the most
I'm glad it's thing I would kind of like
to see the rest of the family too or
like stop by the Adam's house just to
feel like because this is its own new
universe ostensibly so you know I would
like to by the end of this get a whole
sense for what The Adams Family life is
like yeah I think the environment's
really good here though we're we're
setting at this Nevermore High School uh
very Hogwarts meets Xavier's School for
the gifted yeah it's it's a cool it's a
cool layer and I like the I like the
Aesthetics a lot of what they've brought
to life I think they've and really
nailed that down and there's a good
blend of practical ncgi I mean the Tim
Burton of today is gonna be very
annoying with the CGI because that's
like you have consistently pointed out
over the years of how uh you know cgis
become like the death for Tim Burton in
a lot of ways and I I appreciated that
it seemed like they
there are times where I'm like okay it
took me a while to tell that was CGI but
a lot of times seems like they only
really used it when they needed to sure
and even at times when it looks a little
wonky it doesn't bother me because it's
part of the spirit and the like like the
werewolf at the end looks like really
it's not the greatest CGI but it doesn't
bother me because as long as the
emotionality and the engagement with the
scene is still happening then that's all
that really counts I'm gonna make
Goosebumps yeah no there's a there the
part that made me go 90 like in the
beginning it starts off like 80s high
school movie but the parts that make me
feel like a 90s movie which I guess is
appropriate for the is Adam Sandler
movies or 90s right yeah I think they're
early early 90s yeah it was when uh the
Gwendolyn Christie pulls up in the
family van like I haven't seen that van
since like the 90s yeah yeah that's when
I had that um awareness of it and yeah I
mean like the the roommate and her I
feel like have a amazing chemistry I
think it's really good and I could see
already the Inception of that how that's
going to evolve over time because
there's other scenes that especially
when it comes to Pilots where I can hear
the the actor reading together I could
hear a bit of the audition sides as they
call them when you audition and not that
like everyone here I thought actually
did a really good job it was just
certain like chemistry read scenes like
with the the first scene with
um the self-tortured artist I don't want
this to sound like I I didn't like that
like I appreciate all the context and I
think they both did a good job with that
that did have a
a sound to it that was like yeah it
sounds like actors are like reading
together and and then also the uh the
the guy in the coffee shop Tyler Tyler
but I still like them though I don't
want that to sound like I still like
them you know uh but there are times
where kind of pull me out and I do think
there was
like this is like Danny this is like
pure Danny elf score and I love that I
love that like it's Danny elfman's score
with Tim Burton it's just awesome to
hear that I love most of the music there
were times rarely out of an hour-long
episode but there were times where I'm
like you can kind of lower the volume a
little bit
we get it guys because sometimes when
they didn't have music I was like I was
more pulled into the scene yeah and
sometimes it becomes a little
overwhelming
yeah and most people probably aren't
watching this headphones like we are
yeah so over to watch it with like
headphones I really get the surround
sound like there is so much like the
music does not stop
um that being said I'd rather have the
music than not have the music like I
said when I said qualms there I would
say they were like little I'm sure to
some people there are not bothersome
whatsoever but it does have that
classical Gothic Danny Elfman tune that
you'd want when you're hearing the
adaptation of Wednesday Adams it almost
feels like like from behind the camera
you can feel the enthusiasm so as the
viewer you're like okay okay pull it
back a little bit I'm happy you're here
I'm happy you're here I'm happy you're
doing your thing pull it back over here
yeah restrain it a little bit because
because that's kind of the nice surprise
here is that while there are elements in
which I would love to see them go
incredibly Bonkers I do appreciate that
for this pilot you know it's restrained
in the right ways sure yeah and uh and
two like you said I think there is I'll
be interested to see how everybody
acclimates to the dialogue because this
is one of those shows that I think also
has a Razor's Edge to walk on when it
comes to that kind of writing because
dialogue has to be stylized and you've
got to have everybody able to deliver it
without it sounding too precocious or
pretentious or like ah you think that
your dialogue is super Snappy and all
that stuff and and I've I've heard not
really specifics but I've heard uh tell
of Jenna Ortega kind of throwing things
out for takes and things like that and a
lot of those takes being the ones that
made it to the final product and so it
seems like an exciting opportunity Unity
for you know one of those uh you know
sort of lightning in a bottle casting
moments where yeah somebody becomes like
the custodian of a character and like
really infuses it with their own you
know sort of life and enthusiasm and and
yeah like I'm just excited to see how it
builds and it's like all the elements
are here nothing is is too out of whack
to the point where I think it will you
know drop off or or you know fall in a
Hole uh but there's still like little
bits of room for improvement obviously
like I'm really I want to see Uncle
Fester at some point I feel like that's
the thing I'm looking forward to the
most
um so Fred armisen's plan yes yeah I
believe so that was see he appears like
once in the trailer I think so okay yeah
so that was that was big excitement for
me like and I like the casting of the
rest of the atoms I I really liked
Pugsley a lot for his like brief
inclusion I want to see more of Louise
Guzman and Catherine Zeta Jones together
because I I appreciate what the scenes
necessitate them doing but I also want
to see them in like full full form sure
yeah I'm not I don't really uh like
they're fine mostly I'm okay with
waiting for yeah I'm not itching but I
mean you have more of a
well built-in love oh yeah I guess maybe
the the thing to to Circle back around
what you said earlier like that's the
one thing that I think you will benefit
like you can I think watch this with no
prior knowledge and this will probably
be the Gateway for a lot of people into
atoms anything but as yeah if you've
seen the old stuff it kind of relies on
you understanding those basic principles
because they're not going to use more
tissue or Gomez or Pugsley very much or
Lurch or any of that you know like I
don't know if any other auxiliary
characters like Grandma or cousin it or
anything come into play but yeah like
they with those bits and pieces when
they're driving to the school I thought
they were first gonna drive like to the
Adam's house just to establish that and
they you know they don't they don't have
to but that's something that does rely
on sort of like okay either you'll catch
up later or you just kind of know and
and that's not what we're trying to do
here so we're gonna brush past that
stuff
but I don't think anybody would be lost
or anything like that yeah yeah you get
once you get Wednesday and you see what
family she comes from you understand the
the gag of the atoms yeah yeah and and I
did I do think the Comedy Works and I
think the writing and I don't know what
lines Jenna ortegos the ones that she
came up with and the writers came up
with but I think there's a there's a
great type of witty comeback to how she
delivers those lines and the way they're
written too yeah that always sound
um like that is how what this character
of Wednesday how she would frame like
something as little as
um oh what does she say about the
pilgrim shoe the buckle buckle show if
the buckled Shoe Fits yeah yeah so the
same if the shoe fits she says if the
buckled shoe fits you know it's just a
little extra salt on there oh yeah I
think she's yeah every comeback she's
always she's always very cool as she
needs to be yeah and it never fails her
there and that's that's good yeah and
and of course uh yeah that with with
thing I think the uh effects of thing
are phenomenal terminal and yeah the way
because it's always been like a great
gimmick of thing but it's never felt
more alive like you really feel like a
personality that's that's got to be a
real hand
I'm no yeah totally yeah so it made it
does make me wonder like how they film
certain parts sure
um sure especially when there are when
it's less of like when it's just like a
shot on thing you're like okay I can see
what probably happened here but yeah
when in the more complex shots yeah I'd
be curious to know if like how many
scenes were it like there must have been
certain shots where they allowed Jenna
Ortega to interact with the real hand
yeah like he was just there and she had
to like zone out the green yeah not
think about the dude in the blue body
sock just to talk to the hand or
literally talk to the hand and I think I
think the way his there was so much
expression yeah and I was I was
surprised like like both thing and Jenna
Ortega they they have that instant I
know this character yeah yes yeah and
not because I know Adam I don't know
Adam's family that well I really don't
um there's a very deep complex lore
you're missing like I've seen the movie
saying like I didn't even watch the
sequel you know so
there's a reaction and it didn't grow up
family values go watch that I've seen
like passing episodes of as I I didn't
grow up cartoons yeah and not the
cartoons
um was there cartoons weren't there
cartoons where's the cartoons I feel
like there are cartoons I mean there's
certainly like comic strips there was
the black and white old TV show yeah
yeah the movies there's the animated
movie they made recently yeah yeah yeah
so I'm not that familiar
um but like this interpretation I really
got uh but I like the Mysteries they
have a foot as well and I think the
supernatural angle is a is an intriguing
one very modern day yeah she's got those
Visions you got those Christopher Walken
Visions it's not part of it right uh not
my Recollections Family original Edition
okay no because I mean yeah like the if
we're going way back like it's a lot
more innocuous than that
um and it's just yeah mostly that fish
out of water quality and then in the
movies with like Christina Ricci is
Wednesday Adams I don't I don't remember
there being any distinct telekinetic
thing they just they just kind of exist
outside the the realm of normal physics
yeah you know but yeah this is I think
this is a contrivance for this show the
whole death Visions oh yeah she's finds
the right Spirit to channel here Jenna
Ortega because this easily could have
been very one note in caricature it
could and she manages to she's always
listening she's always processing yeah
that's the great part while being a you
know that that's dry delivery kind of
character she's still
finds just the right Shades to express
or emote a tiny bit more to clue Us in
and there's always more going on behind
the eyes uh than just like don't blink
and stare there's always so much more
happening there's more soul to her and I
think that's a great touch so yeah guys
uh solo first start for Wednesday we'll
see how the rest of the episodes go the
only thing I've heard is there's like a
dance scene that is the meme that's the
main thing I've heard I I haven't seen a
moment of it so yeah yeah I've seen if
anything I've seen the classic of the
little girls like black and white doing
the dance but I don't know if it's the
same dance yeah but it's it's
reminiscent at least that's all I've
heard is there's some dancing so we'll
have to limber up for that episode
whenever that happens yeah we'll see how
that goes alrighty guys well what do you
think about our reaction
should we react differently yeah do we
have to do it is this a little a little
bit of change here subscribe leave a
like and listen us with a patreon
James the Smith Smith you got that
Gothic spelling on your name I like it
it's like old timey like a Wednesday
Adams mystery story plot
I hope you're feeling well here at the
end of the year I hope you are feeling
colorful and optimistic unless you know
unless you're that kind of person unless
you like a dreary day a monochrome maybe
that's what makes you happy I hope
you're able to enjoy that as well either
way thanks for sticking on our patreon
thanks for you know believing in the
freaks of the reject nation and not
rejecting us for our outward appearances
but for our inward qualities you're a
good dude James Smith and I hope you're
having a a merry holiday season and a
Happy New Year
that was surprisingly normal ah because
you know I pulled the normals out for
the weird shows man that's how I like to
create irony I embrace myself for a
roller coaster and then here we are like
oh wow that was it we didn't know drops
no Loops subversions G yeah that's one
hell of a subversion there's a why in
Wednesday James Smith which means at the
heart of your last name is the end of
Wednesday's name which makes you the
thing of them
[Music]